こんにちは
はじめしゃちょーです
今日は何日か知っていますか?
そう
今日は
四月の一日
エイプリルフールでございます
いままさきと車に乗ってるんですけども
ちょっと彼に
とびっきりのドッキリチックな
嘘をついてやろうとおもいます
かなりけっこう計画的にねってきているので
たぶんおもしろいと思うんですけども
この車レンタカーです
レンタカーで車を借りて
今この中にまさきの財布とかカバンとか
この中にまさきのさいふとか鞄とかいろんなものが入っています
いろんなものが入っています。
今からまさきに、嘘の企画を言ってて
今からまさきにウソの企画を言ってて
今から二人で旅行動画、旅動画を車で撮ろうと
今から旅行動画、旅動画を車でとろうと
鍵持ってる？
鍵もってる？！車の鍵！
車の鍵
車の鍵持ってる？
車の鍵持ってる？！
座席に置いてなかった？！
あった！
まさき迎えに行く設定だから
ちょっと待ってて！
で、いまから旅動画をとるわけなんですけども
ちょっと、恥ずかしい、恥ずかしい、恥ずかしい
まさきなにか買いに行ってて！
声聞こえないここ？！
なんか買いに行ってて！
LINEするわ！LINEする！
ETCカードが挿入されていません
まさきと車で旅動画をとると話をしてて
今から彼は旅動画をとると思い込んでいます
ガチで
オープニングとるって言って１人でいるんですけども
今回の企画は
レンタカーってとこが怖いですよね
後輩二人と連絡をとってまして
もうすぐこの近くに来ます
もしもし？ポジションついた？
「トラックの裏に」
OK！バッチリ
レンタカーの場所分かる？
じゃあ、ちょっとまたLINEで合図したら車入ってきて！
はい！GOOD LUCK
今、仕掛け人で後輩を二人呼んでて
その二人に泥棒役をやってもらいます
俺たちがつかうこの車が
盗まれて、運転されて
プップーって行っちゃったら
どういう反応をするのか
まぁちょっと、エイプリルフールなんでね、ドキッとさせたいわけですよ
てわけでもうすぐ、まさきが入ってくるんで
ちょっと外でオープニングを撮ります！
オープニングを撮ってる間に勝手にこの車が動き出して
行っちゃうっていうドッキリです！
もっと念入りに話しておこう！
もしもし？えっと、移動するルートなんだけど
信号側に行ってほしいんだよね！左の
それだったら、俺が歩道走りながら移動できるから
法定速度で、そうそうそう
もうすぐ、まさき車に入ってくるから
そろそろ、準備のほうを
ありがとうございます！よろしくお願いします
盗まれる車！走る俺！
困惑するまさき！
はたして、どうなるのでしょうか！
このスタートもありだけど
外で普通にはいっ！やるほうがよくね？！
それで、車にぴょぴょぴょって入ってきたほうが
ほんとにこれで撮るの？！
ま）そうじゃないと２カメ使えなくない？
確かにそうだ。じゃあそれで行きましょう
アングルおかしいけどね
こんにちわ！はじめしゃちょーと
ま）まさき
ついに春休みも終わりですよ
ま）終わりますね。
今年は全然出かけてないと思った
だから春休みの最後ぐらいはね
まさきと軽くドライブチックなちょっと落ち着いた動画を撮ろうかなと思います！
せっかくの休みなんで今日はドライブしに行きましょう！
ま）はい！いこう！
ちょっと待っててね
このあと行き場所を言わなきゃいけないから
撮れてるよね？！てか
はい！というわけで今回の行き場所なんですけども
静岡ということで
いろんな名所がある
声入ってんのかな？！
入りずらくない？！
待って待って！
俺たちの車じゃね？！
はぁ？
なんで
ちょ、待って待って
盗まれる車
走る俺
困惑するまさき
ま）割と困るんだけど
結構やばくね？！
ま）早く警察呼ぼ！
まさき
ま）待って、俺も泣きそうなんだけど
まさき！ドッキリ
ドッキリ大成功！！
ま）はぁ？
ドッキリ大成功！
ま）待って！どういうこと？
ま）えっ！すげぇ慌ててカメラ止めて
ま）もう、どうしようと思って
はい！というわけでドッキリ大成功です！
ま）いやー、もうほんと
ま）まじ、あの車の中にある自分の物考えて
ま）やばいやばい！と思って
もうすぐ、車帰ってくるんでしばしお待ちを
ま）いやまじか！
ま）俺ほんとにもう、今年度終わったなと思った
ま）いやー、戻ってきたね
ドッキリ大成功！！
ま）くっそ
レンタカーを返しに行ったら、レンタカーの店員さんに
「昨日の動画面白かったですよ☺」と言われ
少し汗をかいた
23歳の朝